let's consider our one-dimensional
collision again object one moving with
velocity v1 initial and object two
moving with the two initial let's call
this our I hat direction and the [ __ ]
this is our initial state and our final
state after the collision we have object
one we'll say it's moving this way be
one final an object two moving that way
B two final now recall our principle of
impulse and momentum we said that if
there is an external force during the
time of a collision delta T then
physically that will cause the momentum
of the system final minus the momentum
of the system initial now when we do
this analysis this side was a
description and this side is physics now
for our one-dimensional collision we
need to look at this collision and ask
ourselves are there any external forces
acting on the system which is consisting
of particle one and particle two so what
we're going to identify here is that
this surface is frictionless and will
ignore all air resistance and so by our
assumptions that there are no F external
is zero and therefore the momentum of
the system remains constant so here our
statement is many people call this
conservation of momentum but we're
saying in this example based on our
assumptions that the momentum of the
system is constant
now how do we actually write that down
well let's now write it first as vector
expressions so we have the initial
momentum be one of the system m1 m2 be
to initial is equal to the final
momentum of the system be one final plus
m2 be to final now how do we represent
these equations well you could treat
them as vectors if you wanted but what
we're gonna do is express them as
components so if we wrote this as
components we would have m1 the X
initial I hat plus M to be 2 X initial I
hat equals m1 the 1x final I hat plus
m2v2
X final I have 2 so that's the vector
expression expressed in terms of
components the advantage of this is that
we really don't know the signs of these
two final components that's our target
quantities but we could just write this
equation instead of writing it as a
vector equation let's just now write
this as a component equation and when we
write this equation in terms of
components we have M 1 B 1 X initial
plus m2v2 X initial equals M 1 V 1 X
final plus m2v2 X final and this
equation here is the equation that we'll
use to express the constancy of the
momentum of the system we'll call this
equation 1
now our next approach is to ask are
there any other quantities in the system
which are constant